[Musique]
on n'arrête pas le progrès et le progrès
donne raison aux automobilistes pressés
contre la voiture à bras qui se traîne
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi désormais nous ne verrons
sans doute plus le petit déménageurs on
envoyait encore quelques-uns transporté
ses pénates d'un bout à l'autre de paris
le moteur vient de marquer un nouveau
point un décret va étendre à toute la
capitale l'interdiction aux voitures à
bras de circuler
[Musique]
on aurait pu évidemment envisager
d'autres solutions moins radicales
rendre obligatoire le port des patins à
roulettes par exemple ce qui eût permis
d'aller plus vite ou bien encore obligé
les usagers des voitures abraham unir
leurs véhicules d'un quelconque système
de démultiplication tel celui de
l'inventeur bien connu claude b cogner
qui est permis lui aussi d'accélérer le
mouvement
et ces solutions semble-t-il ont dû être
écartés à cause des excès de vitesse due
à de possibles pertes du contrôle
[Musique]
et ce temps on a choisi l'interdiction